aktuell gibt es gefühlt jeden tag neue
entwicklungen erkenntnisse und
ankündigungen zum thema corona wir haben
dieses video hier ursprünglich am
freitag dem 24
april gedreht und dann gab es am
wochenende direkt neue infos die wieder
alles umgeschmissen haben
jetzt haben wir teile des videos neu
gedreht heute am montag den 27 april und
müssten jetzt einen redaktionsschluss
machen das kann aber sehr gut sein dass
einige der infos die wir hier nennen
bereits veraltet sind wenn ihr das video
hier schaut gut also gerne mal unten in
die video beschreibung da haben wir
nicht nur alle quellen zu unseren
aussagen verlinkt sondern halten auch
fest falls sich an diesen informationen
inzwischen etwas geändert haben sollte
seitdem zwanzigster april dürfen
geschäfte unter strengen auflagen den
betrieb wieder aufnehmen
das kontaktverbot bleibt aktuell zwar
bestehen aber die angst vor einer
zweiten infektionswelle ist groß
währenddessen wächst der druck auf die
politik gesellschaft wirtschaft und
medien verlangen einen konkreten
fahrplan wie die nächsten schritte im
kampf gegen das virus aussehen um die
infektionsrate weiter unten zu halten
und krankenhäuser zu entlasten könnten
wir im lockdown bleiben bis ein
impfstoff gefunden ist
der kommt aber frühestens anfang
nächsten jahres und alle möglichen
faktoren könnten dieses datum noch
weiter nach hinten schieben
schon jetzt werden aufgrund der
kontaktsperre immer mehr leute in
kurzarbeit geschickt beurlaubt oder
sogar gekündigt kleine und große
unternehmen bekommen finanzhilfen um es
durch den lockout zu schaffen und bei
psychisch vorbelasteten personen
hinterlässt die kontaktsperre auch ihre
spuren
das virus und die maßnahmen sorgen für
angst und unsicherheit so einen lock
down noch ein ganzes jahr beizubehalten
ist wirtschaftlich und sozial beinahe
unmöglich eine weitere möglichkeit ist
die sogenannte durchseuchung sukzessive
infizieren sich die vermutlich
benötigten 60 bis 70 prozent der
gesellschaft um eine herde limonit
aufzubauen
hierfür haben wir maßnahmen wie kontakt
sperrungen und schulschließungen immer
wieder auf damit sich leute anstecken
und führen die maßnahmen dann wieder ein
so weit das gesundheitssystem an seine
grenzen kommt modellierungen sagen aber
voraus dass es mit dieser methode
drei der vier bis fünf jahre dauern wird
bis wir eine herdenimmunität erreicht
haben und so eine durchseuchung ist
unvorhersehbar
wir schauen bei diesem virus ja immer in
die vergangenheit die fälle die heute
bekanntgegeben werden haben sich bereits
letzte oder vielleicht sogar schon
vorletzte woche angesteckt schnell
reagieren und zurück in einen lock down
kannst du spät kommen und dann ist der
schaden vielleicht schon angerichtet und
selbst wenn unser gesundheitssystem
standhält bei einer durchsuchung von 60
prozent in einer sterberate vermögen auf
fünf prozent würden wir kleinen
rechnerisch 243.000 menschen verlieren
nur die risikogruppen über so einen
langen zeitraum von drei jahren zu
isolieren ist auch keine option
das sind alles keine guten aussichten
berechtigterweise fragen sich gerade
viele wie kommen wir da wieder raus was
machen wir jetzt
nun eine möglichkeit möchte ich mir
heute genauer anschauen
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass dieses
virus tatsächlich verschwindet klingt
ein bisschen absurd aber es gibt
eine präzise nachverfolgen
infektionsketten
zur zeit hat man den eindruck als und
jeder annacone ab
geht auch um datenschutz punkt vorne
sitzt der europäische weg
wenn wir schneller sind als das virus
dann haben wir eine chance
die bundesregierung hat sich mitte april
dazu entschlossen stückweise verbot
aufzuheben und diese wieder einzuführen
falls die infektionsrate hochschulen
sollte experten gehen davon aus dass das
passieren wird
sachsens ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer und andere mitglieder der
bundesregierung sprechen von einer neuen
normalität der plan ist also koexistenz
mit dem virus freiheitseinschränkende
maßnahmen verbote und eine absolute
notsituation als normalität zu betiteln
finde ich erst mal aus demokratischer
sicht sehr problematisch aber auch
wissenschaftlich gibt es einwände gegen
diesen plan
experten fürchten hier eine gefährliche
gratwanderung am rande einer kritischen
infektionsrate genau wie bei einer
aktiven durchseuchung haben wir auch
hier mit zwei wochen verzögerungen zu
kämpfen bis die fallzahlen eintreffen
deswegen wird von vielen aktuell geraten
die lok tor maßnahmen tatsächlich noch
zu verschärfen
die infektionsrate für einige wochen
soweit wie möglich runter zu drücken so
dass die aktiven fälle erst mal auf eine
verfolgbare level gesunken sind
erst dann könnten behörden mit dem
sogenannten containment also der
eindämmung beginnen
das bedeutet einzelnen infektionsketten
nachverfolgen
jeder der mit einem infizierten kontakt
hatte wird aufgesucht kontaktiert und
angewiesen sich in situationen zu
begeben
aktuell wird das in deutschland per
telefon und e mail versucht das ist
detektivarbeit die oft mühsam und
zeitraubend ist und ganz bildlich
gesprochen
mit bleistift und papier stattfindet das
ist brigitte straff wald epidemiologin
an der lmu münchen
nachdem die kontaktpersonen ermittelt
wurden müssen diese benachrichtigt
werden
dafür müssen kontaktdaten allerdings
bekannt sein also telefonnummer oder
e-mail-adresse zum beispiel seine
verfolgung funktioniert aber nur schnell
genug bei direkten angehörigen an die
man sich auch erinnern kann geht es um
kontakt mit fremden personen würde schon
schwieriger oder könnt ihr euch noch
daran erinnern hinter wem ihr vor einer
woche an der supermarktkasse gestanden
habt ich kann's nicht deswegen dieser
schritt kostet zeit oft viel ist auch
nicht immer erfolgreich alle kontakte
finden wir auf den wegen nicht immer
heraus containment per telefon und
e-mail ist im relativ kleinen heinsberg
und der berüchtigten karnevalsfeier
bereits an seine grenzen gestoßen
schon hier war die infektionskette zu
groß um nur per telefon
hinterherzukommen für flächendeckendes
containment ist die infektionsrate zu
hoch und uns viele werkzeuge und
infrastruktur und jetzt kommen wir
endlich zum eigentlichen thema dieses
videos der streit und die korona ohne
risiko ohne stichwort heißt hier tracing
gerade sprechen alle über corona apps
mit denen soll es möglich sein eine
infektionskette automatisiert und
digital nachzuverfolgen
das ermöglicht es uns wahrscheinlich
auch bei einer höheren infektionsrate
hinterherzukommen der deutsche
gesundheitsminister jens spahn das
robert koch institut und das oxid haben
sich bereits für solche apps
ausgesprochen
gleichzeitig arbeiten google und apple
gemeinsam an einem software gerüst das
gesundheitsministerium weltweit
verwenden können um ihre eigenen apps zu
bauen
aber wie würden solche apps überhaupt
aussehen
zunächst gibt es zwei verschiedene
ansätze tracking & tracing bei einer
trekking app werden unter anderem
bewegungsabläufe aufgezeichnet die app
weist also wo du dich zu welchem
zeitpunkt befindest beim tracy hingegen
werden nur direkte kontakte
aufgezeichnet das bei smartphones die
sich für einen gewissen zeitraum nahe
genug beieinander befinden tauschen
informationen aus
mit hilfe dieser informationen können
dann alle kontakte informiert werden
falls sich jemand angesteckt hat
herausfinden wo und von wem ich mich
angesteckt habe kann ich allerdings
nicht hier in deutschland geht es
aktuell nur um letzteres gibt racing
erst unter diesen gibt es wiederum
mehrere ansätze
erst hat die bundesregierung lange zeit
ein zentralisiertes speicherverfahren
verfolgt dass man per pc genannt hat pan
european privacy pries irving proximity
tracing super name den man sich ganz
toll merken kann
nachdem es aber immer wieder kritik
gehabt und sich 300 experten in einem
offenen brief gegen eine zentrale
speicherung ausgesprochen haben hat man
sich am 25 april um entschieden und
setzt nun auf ein dezentralisiertes
system das finden viele datenschützer
und zum beispiel auch der chaos computer
club deutlich fester wie das system
umgesetzt wird ist aktuell noch nicht
klar
es könnte der gegenentwurf zur apple tdp
3t werden
die central ist greife serving rockcity
tracing auch das ein sehr kreativer name
was aber klar ist man wird
höchstwahrscheinlich die schnittstelle
nutzen die apple und google
bereitstellen wollen
beinahe alle smartphones laufen aktuell
entweder auf android oder ios die beiden
konkurrenten wollen bis mitte mai eine
möglichkeit schaffen mit der
gesundheitsämter oder regierungen ihre
eigenen apps programmieren können
diese braucht man übrigens um das
tracing zu aktivieren selbst wenn ihr
also die schnittstelle mit einem der
nächsten updates auf ein smartphone
bekommt nehmt ihr nicht automatisch teil
das system ist freiwillig wenn ihr die
app aber runter ladet dann sendet euer
smartphone per bluetooth low energy
permanent neu generierte dies und
empfängt die aldis anderer gerät sind
diese id es werden nur lokal auf den
smartphones gespeichert und nach einer
bestimmten zeit auch wieder gelöscht
wie lange man in welchem abstand sein
muss um als kontakt zu zählen das müssen
die gesundheitsämter entscheiden
antwort kann für deutschland anders
aussehen als für italien oder belgien
und selbst berlin oder bayern haben da
vielleicht andere vorstellungen
es gibt sogar ideen für ein system das
an dieser stelle lernen und sich selber
optimieren kann
wenn man sich jetzt infiziert und
positiv auf saas koch 2 getestet wird
dann erhält man so der plan einen
authentifizierungs code vom
gesundheitsamt und kann damit die idee
ist die man selber gesendet hat auf
einen server hochladen
im dezentralen systeme sind das nur die
eigenen adis niemann ausgesendet hat das
ist ganz wichtig mein part als
infizierter ist damit durch alle anderen
apps checken regelmäßig im hintergrund
auf dem server ob da es dabei sind die
sie kennen weil sie damit schon kontakt
hatten
wenn das der fall ist dann schlägt die
app alarm und die person kann sich in
selbst isolation begeben
das gibt uns einen wertvollen zeitlichen
vorsprung denn nach einer infektion
treten symptome erst tage später ein
infektions ist man aber fast immer
bereits vorher während sich ein
infizierter also noch kerngesund fühlt
steckt er bereits andere personen an
würde ein user der app aber schon vor
dem eintreten der symptome in
selbstisolation gehen können dann sind
wir dem virus einen wichtigen schritt
voraus
das heißt es möglich einfach allen
menschen mit symptomen und oder kontakt
pauschal zur isolation zu raten besser
funktioniert so eine app allerdings mit
bestätigten infektionen sich in
deutschland testen zu lassen ist
momentan für alle menschen vorbehalten
die bereits symptome zeigen oder in
systemrelevanten berufen arbeiten aber
man müsste diese beschränkungen ändern
so dass man auch es verdachtsfälle
testen lassen kann eine zu niedrige test
rate ist allerdings nicht das einzige
hindernis einer solchen app vor allem
falls pause tipps und falls nötig können
zu einem problem werden
nun bemerkte eset racing app nähe und
dauer aber ganz viele andere relevante
risikofaktoren nicht wenn wir zum
beispiel im supermarkt anstehen und
zwischen uns möglicherweise eine
plexiglaswand steht dann wäre trotz der
eigentlich gemessenen ehe das risiko
deutlich geringer das kann diese app
nicht erkennen nicht sehen nicht
verstehen
und in diesen fällen könnte sie dann
eine falsch positive meldung geht es
geht natürlich auch umgekehrt das kann
jemand im supermarkt weiter weg stehen
als die empfohlenen anderthalb oder zwei
meter aber heftig vor sich hin husten
oder niesen
das wird die app auch nicht registrieren
dass in dem fall haben wir falsch
negative meldungen also keine was
wiederum in falscher sicherheit wiegen
kann wie schon erwähnt würde es nicht
bei so einer app aber um ein
freiwilliges modell handeln und ein
kurzer blick auf twitter genügt um zu
sehen dass es hier durchaus bedenken
gibt
[Musik]
hauptzeuge vieler ist hier der
datenschutz klar zu einer app setzen
voraus dass nach einwilligung daten von
einem aufgezeichnet und ausgewertet
werden
deswegen spricht das rk ii davon
nutzerdaten zu polemisieren
die app kennt aber weder meinen namen
noch meine telefonnummer oder meinen
standort nur zufällig generierte id ist
allerdings ist eine pseudo visierung
nicht absolut sicher
oft haben bereits kleine datenschnipsel
gereicht um zb anonyme teilnehmer von
studien zu identifizieren oder auch den
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
falls sie dazu mehr erfahren wollt
schaut euch gerne diesen link hier in
der video beschreibung an der sowohl
pseudonymisiert als anime serie
natürlich immer relativ das ist
professor ulrich kelber der
bundesbeauftragte für datenschutz und
mit seiner behörde tatsächlich das
höchste organ in deutschland zu diesem
thema wenn sie mit sehr hohem aufwand
mit zusätzlichen daten mit viel
rechenpower reingehen können sie viele
pseudonymisiert und anonymisierung
wieder aufheben sie können nicht
anonymisieren bei der tracing app
vollständig weil sie natürlich möchten
dass nachher auch die kontaktpersonen
benachrichtigt werden können um die
pseudonymisiert zu stärken brauchen sie
erstens die richtige it sicherheit
zweitens aber auch daten minimierung
also eine der grundprinzipien des
datenschutzes umso weniger daten sie
haben um so schwierig ist es zurück zu
schließen wichtig ist deswegen dass der
code der app und das back and open
source sind damit wir uns transparent
ansehen können wie das alles
funktioniert open source systeme zu
wählen und zwar bekennt und das ist
übrigens nicht nur eine frage der
transparenz sondern die gemeinschaft
findet auch noch fehler
ich finde dieses bewusstsein der
deutschen bevölkerung erst mal mut zu
sagen es geht auch datenschutzkonform
das ist der europäische datenschutz
verhindert kein gesundheitsschutz
datenschutz verhindert keine
sicherheitspolitik datenschutz
verhindert keine digitalisierung sondern
schafft er bessere digitalisierung man
denkt am anfang nach
und wählt die richtige architektur etwas
zu machen nicht mit dem tag des starts
ist der datenschutz vorbei sind und dann
beginnt eigentlich erst richtung okay
das waren jetzt eine menge
gegenargumente einschränkungen und noch
viele offene fragen
nehmen wir trotzdem mal an diese
kritikpunkte könnten aus dem weg geräumt
werden
wir haben also eine sichere funktionale
lösungen dann bleibt uns aber immer noch
vielleicht unser größtes problem ist
eine freiwillige teilnahme genug dirk
brockmann vom rkw schätzt dass wir
mindestens die hälfte der bevölkerung
als teilnehmer bräuchten um effektives
containment zu betreiben
das sind mehr als 41 millionen menschen
in deutschland die sich alle eine app
herunterladen müssten laut dieser
statistik hier hatten in deutschland
2018 nur 57 millionen menschen ein
smartphone
tendenz steigend ja aber viel spielraum
ist dann nicht gerade ältere menschen
die zur risikogruppe gehören haben ganz
oft keine andere menschen werden sich
gegen die nutzung einer app entscheiden
ende februar 2020 hatte südkorea nach
china den weltweit schlimmsten corona
befallen mittlerweile haben europa die
usa und viele weitere länder südkorea
lange überholt dort bleiben die
infektionen eingedämmt und das leben
geht mehr oder weniger normal weiter
unter anderem mit hilfe von smartphone
daten und öffentlichen kameras ist es
gelungen die infektionsketten von der
ersten kugel 19 patienten an
nachzuverfolgen
so konnte südkorea das corona virus auf
beeindruckende art und weise eindämmen
ohne das öffentliche leben komplett zum
erliegen zu bringen
dieses system funktioniert aber nicht
auf freiwilliger basis sei 2015 darf die
südkoreanische regierung während eines
krankheitsausbruchs auf die handydaten
der patienten und überwachungskamera
aufnahmen zu greifen
alle schritte die ein patient iks tätigt
werden gespeichert und veröffentlicht um
so andere bürger von diesen orten
fernzuhalten
wenn also in meiner nähe ein fall
getrennt wurde bekomme ich eine
smartphone warnung mit genauen
informationen über die infizierte person
alter beruf geschlecht sollte sich
meinen weg trotz aller warnungen mit
einer infizierten person gekreuzt haben
werde auch ich getestet und meine
kontakte nachverfolgt
das problem von mangelnden teilnehmern
wurde in südkorea also gelöst
aber zu welchem preis die vergangenheit
hat gezeigt dass notsituationen oft
ausgenutzt wurden um restriktive oder
kontrollieren der mechanismen
einzuführen die dann nicht wieder
umgekehrt wurden
südkorea hat das tracking von
smartphones 2015 eingeführt und benutzt
es jetzt wieder wenn auch zu einem
ähnlichen zweck und generell für das
allgemeinwohl
es stellt sich also die berechtigte
frage ob das aufzeichnen von smartphones
ein wiederkehrendes verfahren werden
könnte der die daten sind natürlich umso
mehr daten im umlauf sind umso mehr kann
ich an erkenntnissen gewinnen wir sind
jetzt 20 jahre seit den anschlägen 2001
wo der staat eine sicherheitsmaßnahme
nach der andere greift ein datum nach
dem anderen erhebt natürlich solche
daten dazu genommen würden wenn man
versuchen würde aus einer vielleicht
sogar pseudonym aufgenommenen daten mit
anderen wieder zur personalisierten dann
würde es die gesamt überwachung
natürlich noch einmal verstärken
aber es sieht so aus als würde apple und
google selber wollen dass der service
nach überstehen der pandemie wieder
eingestellt wird
trotzdem ich muss zugeben dass ich noch
wesentlich optimistischer über eine
krone app nachgedacht hatte als wir mit
den recherchen zu diesem thema begonnen
haben
[Musik]
ehrlicherweise wird auch eine vollkommen
anonymisiert racing app viele probleme
die wir momentan haben überhaupt nicht
lösen und das ist die meinung der
ausstattung in gesundheitsämtern das ist
die die mangelnde bestehende
it-infrastruktur die er weit vor diesen
tracing apps überhaupt nicht
funktioniert wir haben nach wie vor die
situation dass gesundheitsämter daten an
die landesämter faxen müssen diese faxe
einfach überlastet sind dann müssen
händisch daten aufbereitet werden um sie
dann als rk ii zu melden wir haben
vorher so viele baustellen die die jetzt
gar nichts mit datenschutz zu tun haben
und auch gar nichts mit high tech oder
apps zu tun haben sondern die einfach
noch so schlecht sind und uns aber bei
der bewältigung der pandemie ehrlich
behindern aber ist so eine app jetzt
wirklich eine schlechte idee
was die apps bieten ist vor allem die
chance sehr früh sehr gezielt
einzugreifen
aber auch da es muss exakt vorab geklärt
werden was eigentlich bei dieser risiko
meldung auf dem handy
konkret zu tun ist zu hause bleiben
testen lassen oder irgendeine andere
verhaltensweise in den fällen ist
bislang kein test vorgesehen ob
freiwillig oder als pflicht tracking und
daten sammeln wirft wichtige fragen auf
wie es jetzt weitergeht bleibt erstmal
ungewiss die bundeskanzlerin hat
angekündigt das personal der
gesundheitsämter aufzustocken
berichten zufolge sollen 4000
fünfköpfige team ist im überblick über
jeweils 20.000 bürger behalten ohne
hilfsmittel wird das schwierig waren
allerdings eine app kommen könnte ist
zum zeitpunkt dieses drehte gerade noch
überhaupt nicht klar
ich glaube wir haben mit der krone app
in deutschland die chance zu beweisen
dass freiwillige partizipation aus
solidarität funktionieren kann
aber was sagt ihr dazu würdet ihr euch
die korona app installieren wenn sie für
datenschutzkonform befunden wird hier
oben könnt ihr darüber abstimmen
ansonsten wenn ihr noch mehr
hintergründe und informationen zu diesem
thema und generell über carola haben
wollt dann kann ich euch die debatte ans
herz legen
dort geht es um komplexe vielschichtige
themen mit vielen argumenten auf beiden
seiten und die macher schaffen ist immer
wieder eine neutrale und vor allem
faktenbasierte debatte zu leiten
ich hab ich die website mal unten in der
video beschreibung verlinkt außerdem
haben wir das komplette interview mit
professor ulrich kelber auch nochmal
hochgeladen und unten in der video
beschreibung verlinkt für alle die sich
das gerne ansehen möchten weil er
wirklich viele viele spannende dinge zum
thema datenschutz gesagt hat ansonsten
danke an unsere unterstützer auf patria
neuer support hilft uns aufwendige
videos wie dieses hier auf die beine zu
stellen falls ihr uns und unsere arbeit
auch unterstützen wollt dann ist patron
auf jeden fall eine gute möglichkeit
dafür
auch dazu ist ein link unten in der
video beschreibung ansonsten bleibt wie
immer neugierig bleibt zu hause
patrick